الان ينضم الينا من جد مارتن جريفيث وكيلو
الامين العام للامم المتحده للشؤون
الانسانيه مرحبا بك سيد مارتن جريث كنت
اليوم زرت مدينه بورتسودان كيف قيمت الوضع
هناك
هذه مدينه تبتدا بشكل سريع كما تعرفون من
الناس الذين يحاولون اللجوء نحو الغرب لكن
هدفي من الذهاب الى بورسودان اليوم هو ان
التقي فريق الامم المتحده وايضا خصوصا ان
التقي بالوكالات الانسانيه السودانيه
خصوصا وايضا الوكالات والمنظمات غير
الحكوميه
الدوليه اردت ان اتحدث معهم ونتناقشوا حول
كيفيه تناقشوا معهم حول كيفيه بامكانهم
القيام باعمارهم في مساعدتي الشعب
السوداني ذكرت في تصريحاتك هناك ان هناك
حزمه مساعدات انسانيه لدى الامم المتحده
بقيمه 200 مليون دولار للسودان ما قوام
هذه المساعدات
هنالك ميزانيه لهذه السنه الى المساعدات
الانسانيه للسودان هي 1.7 مليار دولار
تغطي الطعام والتجهيزات الغذائيه وايضا
والحمايه والامن وكل الامور التي
يحتاجونها الناس في دارفور وفي مناطق اخرى
اكثر منها ايضا من هذه المبلغ كما كان فقط
من جمعي 200 مليون دولار وبالتاكيد الان
سنحتاج الى المزيد بالنتيجه لتبعات الصراع
الذي بدا قبل اسابيع لكن بالنظر الى حجم
الازمه الانسانيه في السودان كيف يمكن
تقييم هذا المبلغ
لقد جمعنا 200 مليونين طلبنا واحد
فاصله سبعه مليار نحتاج الى المزيد نعم
لكن الان نحن نركزه وحسب وفي اطار الازمه
الذي حصلت ليس لا نركز على الارقام هنالك
هذه مساعدات لم تصل ما نركز عليه هو على
العمليات ما تحتاجه الوكالات الاغاثه
الانسانيه لكي تتمكن هذه الوكالات من
مساعده الناس في الخرطوم ومن جعل مثلا
المستشفيات تعمل وفي مساعده الناس في
دارفور هذا كان ما ركزت عليه اليوم
بامكاننا ان نساعد عمال الاغاثه لكننا
نحتاج الى التزام من الجنرلين وتحدثت
اليهما اليوم التزامات منهما ومن قواتهما
من اجل ضمان سلامه وامن عمالي الاغاثه
والضمان توفيري ممرات امنه وعمليات امنه
لايصال المساعدات لشعب السودان ذكر ت انك
تحدثت الى كل من السيد برهان وسيد حميدتي
كيف كان ردهما على موضوع ضمان امكانيه
ادخال هذه المساعدات الى السودان
كلاهما رحب بالفرصه للتحدث معي لكن
اقتراحي كان محددا واعتقد ان هذه نقطه
مهمه اقتراحي كان انني ساذهب الى اي مكان
احتاج فيه للتاقيه بكما او لاي شخص مسؤول
لكي اتحدث عن الالتزامات التي ارغب
بالحصول عليها منكما وايضا لاننا مسؤولين
ايصال المساعدات لشعب السوداني انا لا
يهمني اي مكان باستطاعتي ان ومستعد للذهاب
الى اي مكان في السودان كلا منها هذين
الجنرالين رحب بالفرصه لتقديم هذه
الالتزامات ونحن الان في خوض نقاشي كيف
بامكاننا ان نلبي هذه الالتزامات ونطبقها
ما نوع هذه الالتزامات التي
سيقدمانها ما هو اقتراحكم تحديدا انتم في
الامم المتحده من اجل ضمان ايصال
المساعدات
بدايه
الالتزام العام ولدينا بكتابه هذه النقاط
على ورقه
وبالاعتماد على خبرتنا الدوليه يجب ان
يكون ذلك التزام عام بالاحترام القانون
الدولي وحمايه المنشات المدنيه والمدنيين
وايضا وربما الاهم فيما يتعلق بسؤالك
التزام محدد بسلامه
الممرات الانسانيه بين مثلا بين السودان
وكذلك ايضا اتفاق محدد للسماح لنا
باستخدام المطارات من اجل ايصال المساعدات
جوا من خارج السودان الى مناطق بالقرب من
الاماكن التي تحتاجها بضمنها مثلا في
مناطق المحيطه بالخرطوم بالتاكيد وايضا
التزام
بتمكيننا من ان نكون
متاكدين انه كان هنالك مخازن امنه لان
منها تعرضت
للنهب وهنالك ايضا قوافل تعرضت للنحتاج
الى نظام امن من تحترم فيه القوات
المتحاربه التزاماتها وتضمن سلامه هذه
القوافل الانسانيه لكن سيد معتم برزت في
الايام الماضيه اشكاليه مراقبه هذه
الالتزامات اشكاليه الضامن لهذه
الالتزامات في هذه الحاله من هي الجهه
التي يمكن ان تضمن مثل هكذا التزامات
كلا الطرفان عليهما ان يقوما باحترام هذه
الالتزامات السودان هي ليست الاول مكان
كما تعرفون في العالم
كان علينا ان نعتمد في عملنا الانسانيه
على مثل هذه الضمانات ربما من
الحكومه او من المجموعات المسلحه غالبا
فان يعتمد نظامنا على اعلام الاطراف بحركه
القوافل لكن مساله مسؤوليه وضمان الامن
والسلامه بالتاكيد تقع على عاتق من هو
منخرط في القتال نحن لا زرو اي احكام نحن
لسنا في
خضم من نقرر من هو على حق او على باطل لكن
على الاطراف
يجب ان تحترم هذه القوافل الانسانيه
والسبب في اننا نحتاج الى ذلك لان علينا
ان نفهم التزامات بعضنا البعض ويجب ان
نكون قادرين على ايصال
المساعدات وايصال والقيام بعملنا بعد
اجراء هذه الاجتماعات طيب سيد مارتن الان
نحن في الاسبوع الثالث من هذا من هذه
المواجهات العسكريه في السودان ما هي
مخاوفكم في حال طال امد هذه المواجهات
قد نرى معاناه اسوا من الشعب الانساني
المزيد من النزوح كما تعرفون فان الامام
المتحده قدرت ان اكثر من 100 الف سودانيه
قد ترك البلاد
سيرا على الاقدام نحن نقلق حول سلامه
مساله
اللقاحات وتحدثت مع اليونيسف اليوم وتحدثت
عن خطوره الخطر الذي يتعرض له الاطفال
مثلا نتيجه عدم حصولهم على اللقاحات نقلق
حول مساله الغذاء والبذور قبل موسم
الزراعه لكي يستطيع هنالك لكي يكون هنالك
موسم حصاد بعد ذلك ونخشى من نقص المال وهو
الاساس لاي عمليات
اغاثه وعمليات انسانيه نحتاج الى ان ندفع
الى العاملين الاغاثه ونحن نقلق عن
السودان بشكل عام لكن الان
نعم نرغب برؤيه وقف لاطلاق النار يتم وهذا
ما تم
قطع الوعود به لكن الاحتياجات الانسانيه
لم تختفي الاحتياجات الانسانيه ستظل حتى
بوجود وقف لاطلاق النرويج ان نكون هناك من
اجل ان ندعم الناس الامم المتحده كانت
توقعت الاسبوع الماضي في حاله طال امد هذه
المواجهات ان يخرج من السودان في الايام
المقبله نحو 800 الف شخص وبالتالي هذا
يطرح السؤال حول مخاوف من تصدير هذه
الازمه الى دول الجوار التي تعاني اساسا
من ازمات بدورها ما قولكم في هذا الشان
شعوري انا قلق حول هذا الامر اعتقد ان هذا
الامر خطر ولديه عنصر مزعزع للاستقرار
احدى الامور التي ما رايناه في اثيوبيا
مثلا وايضا الاماكن الاخرى التي قضيت فيه
وقتا طويل كان في القرن الافريقي كان
هنالك خطر المجاعه وايضا مساله نقص
الامطار كل هذه العوامل وكل هذه المجتمعات
هشه بشكل كبير وستتاثر بشكل سلبي اذا ما
استمر هذا الصرع ولقد راينا ايضا
يحدث وتحدثتي عن الارقام الكبيره هذا يعني
ان هنالك حاجه مريحه لايقاف القتال وهذا
امر مهمتي هو ان انظر الى الاحتياجات
الانسانيه للناس خلال القتال وحتى بعد
توقف القتال وان يتم تلبيه هذه الاحتياجات
بشكل كامل شكرا لك كمارت وكيلو الامين
العامله للامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه
حدثنا من مدينه جده